hallo deutsch schule adjektive steigern
hashtag komparativ gut
gut besser am besten das auto gefällt
mir gut das auto gefällt mir gut
das gelbe auto gefällt mir besser als
das rote auto das gelbe auto gefällt mir
besser als das rote auto das blaue auto
gefällt mir am besten das blaue auto
gefällt mir am besten groß
groß größer am größten
die giraffe ist groß die giraffe ist
groß die giraffe ist größer als der
flamingo die giraffe ist größer als der
flamingo die giraffe ist von allen
tieren im zoo am größten
die giraffe ist von allen tieren im zoo
am größten klein klein kleiner
am kleinsten das t shirt in der größe es
ist klein das t shirt in der größe
es ist klein die größe es ist kleiner
als die größe m
die größe es ist kleiner als die größe m
das t shirt in der größe es ist am
kleinsten das t shirt in der größe es
ist am kleinsten welche t shirt größe
hast du langsam langsam langsam
am langsamsten die schildkröte ist
langsam die schildkröte ist langsam die
schildkröte ist langsamer als das huhn
die schildkröte ist langsamer als das
huhn die schildkröte ist am langsamsten
die schildkröte ist am langsamsten
schnell schnell schnell
am schnellsten das auto fährt schnee das
auto fährt schnell das auto fährt
schneller als das fahrrad das auto fährt
schneller als das fahrrad das gelbe auto
fährt am schnellsten das gelbe auto
fährt am schnellsten hoch hoch höher am
höchsten
der schiefe turm von pisa ist hoch der
schiefe turm von pisa ist hoch der big
ben ist höher als der schiefe turm von
pisa der big ben ist höher als der
schiefe turm von pisa
der eiffelturm in paris ist aber am
höchsten
tief tief tiefer am tiefsten
das europäische mittelmeer ist tief das
europäische mittelmeer ist tief der
atlantische ozean ist noch tiefer
der atlantische ozean ist noch tiefer
der pazifische ozean
jahren ist am tiefsten der pazifische
ozean ist am tiefsten heiß heiß heißer
am heißesten in deutschland ist es im
sommer heiß in deutschland ist es im
sommer heiß
[Musik]
in italien ist es im sommer noch heißer
in indien ist es im sommer am heißesten
kalt kalt kälter am kältesten in
deutschland ist es im winter kalt in
deutschland ist es im winter kalt
in russland ist es im winter noch kälter
in der antarktis ist es im winter am
kältesten in der antarktis ist es im
winter am kältesten gesund gesund
gesünder am gesündesten
der apfel ist gesund der apfel ist
gesund die walnuss ist gesünder als ein
apfel die walnuss ist gesünder als ein
apfel sport ist am gesündesten sport ist
am gesündesten machst du auch sport nass
nasa am nassesten wenn es regnet werde
ich nass wenn es regnet werde ich nass
wenn es schneit werde ich noch nasser
bei einem gewitter werde ich am
nassesten bei einem gewitter werde ich
am nassesten hey hey heller am hellsten
eine glühbirne mit einer leistung von 20
watt ist haye eine glühbirne mit einer
leistung von 20 watt ist
hey eine glühbirne mit einer leistung
von 60 watt ist noch heller eine
glühbirne mit einer leistung von 60 watt
ist noch heller eine glühbirne mit einer
leistung von 100 watt ist am hellsten
eine glühbirne mit einer leistung von
100 watt ist am hellsten kurz kurz
kürzer
am kürzesten die haare von ben sind kurz
die haare von ben sind kurz die haare
von alexander sind kürzer als die haare
von ben die haare von alexander sind
kürzer als die haare von ben die haare
von johannes sind am kürzesten die haare
von johannes sind am kürzesten lang lang
länger am längsten
der weg von deutschland nach frankreich
ist lang der weg von deutschland nach
frankreich ist lang der weg von
deutschland nach china ist noch länger
der weg von deutschland nach china ist
noch länger der weg
von deutschland nach australien ist am
längsten
der weg von deutschland nach australien
ist am längsten stark stark stärker am
stärksten
thorsten ist stark thorsten ist stark
emanuel ist stärker als thorsten emanuel
ist stärker als thorsten jochen ist am
stärksten
jochen ist am stärksten
lecker lecker lecker am leckersten
spaghetti mit tomatensoße schmecken
lecker spaghetti mit tomatensoße
schmecken lecker eine pizza isst
leckerer als spaghetti eine pizza isst
leckerer als spaghetti ein bürger menü
ist am leckersten ein burger menü ist am
leckersten was findest du am leckersten
scharf schärfer
am schärfsten japanisches essen ist auf
japanisches essen ist scharf
thailändisches essen ist noch schärfer
mexikanisches essen ist am schärfsten
früh früh früher am frühesten 7 uhr am
morgen ist früh sieben uhr am morgen ist
früh 6 uhr am morgen ist früher als 7
uhr 6 uhr am morgen ist früher als 7 uhr
5 uhr am morgen ist am frühesten 5 uhr
am morgen ist am frühesten spät spät
später am spätesten 21 uhr am abend ist
spät 21 uhr am abend ist spät 22 uhr am
abend ist noch später 22 uhr am abend
ist noch später 23 uhr am abend ist am
spätesten 23 uhr am abend ist am
spätesten teuer teuer
theurer am teuersten
das gelbe poloshirt ist teuer
das blaue polo shirt ist sogar noch
teurer
das rote polo shirt ist aber am
teuersten
teuersten günstig günstig günstiger am
günstigsten
das burger menü ist günstig das burger
menü ist günstig der einzelne bürger ist
noch günstiger der einzelne bürger ist
noch günstiger aber die pommes sind am
günstigsten aber die pommes sind am
günstigsten
fleißig fleißig fleißiger am fleißigsten
tobias lernt fleißig für die
deutschprüfung tobias lernt fleißig für
die deutschprüfung sofia land noch
fleißiger für die deutschprüfung sofia
land noch fleißiger für die
deutschprüfung
alexander lernt am fleißigsten für die
deutschprüfung alexander lernt am
fleißigsten für die deutschprüfung
lernst du auch fleißig deutsch abonniere
den kanal der halle deutsch schule und
aktiviere das kleine glöckchen gib uns
jetzt ein daumen nach oben und klicke
auf diese playlist um weitere videos zum
deutsch lernen zu sehen